Bienvenidos a enlace cono Sur en esta
emisión desde Buenos Aires Argentina en
el programa de hoy haremos una
actualización sobre el uso de las
plantas de Cannabis en el país con un
marco prohibicionista todavía vigente
poco a poco Argentina fue abriendo
rendijas de legalidad para utilizar esta
planta a través de excepciones a la ley
Nacional de drogas uno de los objetivos
es desarrollar un mercado y una
industria según estimaciones oficiales
para el año 2025 la actividad económica
vinculada con el cannabis podría generar
Diez mil nuevos empleos 500 millones de
dólares anuales en ventas al mercado
interno y 50 millones de dólares en
exportaciones
tras la despenalización de la tenencia y
consumo personal en 2009 por parte de la
Corte Suprema uno de los grandes hitos
en el proceso de apertura hacia el
cannabis se dio en 2017 con la
aprobación de la ley de cannabis
medicinal
esa ley tuvo especial impulso por parte
de un grupo de madres de niños con
enfermedades para las que el aceite de
cannabis tiene un efecto terapéutico
Este es mi hijo cuando arrancamos en
2016 Ahora tiene barba el hijo de
Valeria saleche fue diagnosticado con
epilepsia hace unos 8 o 9 años decidió
darle Cannabis para ver si eso lo
ayudaba fue muy bien
no porque haya dejado tener convulsiones
sino porque logré que una persona que
estaba muy medicada súper dopada
totalmente desconectada a la realidad se
conecte conmigo me mira a los ojos
empiece a decir algunas palabras que
antes no decía y eso Fue suficiente como
para agarrar la bandera y decir Bueno
qué hay que hacer para para lograr que
esto le llegue a todo el mundo lo que
hizo Valeria salesh fue organizar ong
que desde 2016 acompaña y orienta a
personas para que cultiven su propio
Cannabis y fabriquen su propio aceite
mamá cultiva tuvo un rol clave en
conseguir la aprobación en 2017 de la
ley de cannabis medicinal una excepción
a la ley de drogas Valeria ve todo su
esfuerzo justificado en el rostro de su
hijo y el canal es lo que le permite es
sonreír y para mí eso hogar para toda la
lucha gasta que me muera pero la ley de
2017 no revertía ciertas restricciones
que dificultaban el acceso al Cannabis y
a la posibilidad de tener plantas
propias eso cambió en marzo de 2021 con
la creación del reprocan el registro de
programa Cannabis al que pueden
inscribirse aquellas personas que
cuenten con una indicación médica y
realicen un trámite ante el Ministerio
de salud de la nación otro paso
importante ha sido la creación en 2022
de la ley para el desarrollo de la
Industria Del Cannabis medicinal y el
cáñamo industrial y ese mismo año
también la autorización para
comercializar semillas de cannabis y
desarrollar variedades eso le ha
permitido a criadores como Facundo
meligene pasar a la legalidad
esto es el registro donde está que es un
criadero de semillas legales está
registrado bajo mi nombre como un
criadero de semillas de cannabis para
hacer fitomejoramiento y poder hacer
ensayos en noviembre de 2022 una semilla
como esta fue la primera que se vendió
legalmente en el marco de la exposición
Expo Cannabis de ese año
y las están comprando toda gente que
está registrada con el reprocan las
andan comprando cultivadores para fumar
mamás para hacer aceite abuelas para
hacer aceite
para todo uso la primera semilla que
vendió su banco en Expo Cannabis 2022 se
la compró una usuaria y médica de 82
años que receta Cannabis a sus pacientes
Generalmente adultos mayores ella empezó
a consumir hace más de cinco años para
superar un dolor crónico que casi no la
dejaba caminar es lo mismo que le sucede
a muchos de sus pacientes
la consulta más común es el dolor
crónico para todos los adultos mayores
que es la mayor cantidad de gente que
atiendo si es una excelentísima arma
terapéutica la situación actual del
Cannabis en Argentina es muy distinta a
la de años atrás en general el
porcentaje de personas a favor de la
despenalización total Aunque regulada es
alto en una encuesta de 2021 de la
cámara Argentina de cannabis más de dos
tercios decían estar a favor eso no
implica que no haya sectores que se
oponen y alarmas vinculadas con el
consumo por parte de poblaciones
vulnerables pero Marcelo morante
coordinador del programa de cannabis del
Ministerio de salud de la nación cree
que el enfoque no debe ser el del
paradigma prohibicionista claramente y
poblaciones que podrían verse afectadas
estamos hablando de los adolescentes
entonces hay que trabajar procesos
educativos porque sabemos que todos los
consumos de sustancias han aumentado en
esa población vulnerable pero realmente
si pensamos y los pensamos como
vulnerables no le vamos a mandar la
policía en ese caso haríamos una
intervención de salud como haríamos
otras ese quiebre en el enfoque es algo
que viene proponiendo desde hace más de
16 años la revista especializada thc
referente del activismo cannábico y
organizadora de Expo Cannabis ellos
abogan por la legalización bajo la
figura de La regulación Total qué es lo
que falta para esa regulación total
Bueno una vez que la sociedad entendió
que el cannabis sirve como medicina que
el cannabis da trabajo Bueno lo que le
falta a la sociedad es aceptar también
que el cannabis produce bienestar que no
hace falta estar mal para querer estar
mejor
los activistas cannábicos creen que el
país está más cerca que nunca de llegar
a esa regulación Total no solo por la
evolución dentro de Argentina sino
también por el contexto regional y
global de despenalización y no dejan de
citar el caso de la progresiva
legalización del Cannabis en Estados
Unidos a la vez como ejemplo y como
fenómeno de legitimización que abre las
puertas para que Argentina siga sus
pasos Gracias por acompañarnos en esta
edición de enlace cono Sur desde Buenos
Aires Argentina Los invito ahora a
seguir con la programación de France 24
[Música]